examine unless it's winning on the spot  I'm really tempted to just move out of  this opinion side step  exactly sidestep anything then I will  have also the chance of going Bishop FC  check for example but Hans calculates he  goes for Bishop F5 checking the eighth  so we're gonna see Queen he check now  Queen and [ __ ] then he wants to go King  no he takes Bishops  look into H4 oh my God  oh my God what what happened here this  is completely insane  this is completely insane  oh wow  oh my God yeah I mean it shows what what  this break does to the players yeah they  they are just completely out of the re  out of freedom and and it's so easy to  blunder I think in such a crazy position  I don't think this was uh as much to do  with the break I think just Hans his  mind space in general uh is a bit shaky  right now but that was the moment